In this lecture, I'm going to teach you how I personally use ABC strategy. See, the method that I've taught you already, it works like a charm. But if you apply the things I'm going to teach you right now, your win rate is going to drastically increase. But it requires a lot of patience. And what I'm going to teach you are A plus ABC setups.
B.C. strategy. So first of all, I would look at the high time frame. So it could be a four hour
market structure, right? Or daily market structure. So if the four hour or high time frame market
structure is bullish, I am going to only look for long positions. Okay? And if the market structure,
let's say is making lower, lower, lower, lower, lower, lower, lower, lower, lower, lower, lower,
No, then I'm only going to look for
Short positions. How I want to see a pullback then another pullback
So an ABC
Oh my god bro, so
ABC within
this leg right here, okay and
This leg
Let me do this. You want to draw out your fib from this move to this move and you want to look for
ABC setup formations above the 0.5 level. Okay? Or I would say this is the like this right here.
So the mid part. So this is 0.5 right. So the mid part above the 0.5 level and this
is like the golden area where you can look for ABC setups.
But generally you can look for ABC setups above the 0.5 level.
So when price comes back above the 0.5 level,
you can drop down so let's assume that you are looking at the
market structure on four hour time for him.
What you can do is you can drop down to 15 minute time for him.
And then you can look for an ABC setup right on a 15 minute
above the 0.5 level and the C leg goes into some sort of a supply zone or an auto block,
okay? Or it could be a fair value gap. So the C leg goes into the fair value gap right
here and then you look for the ABC setup formation, okay? And you take your entry during
kills on ours. So the kills on ours would be from three to six. That is for London session.
And for New York, it's going to be eight. 30, they'll 11, 15. That is New York time. So this right
here is London session. And this is New York session. So your entry must be between these ours.
Okay, that is a must so let me repeat this again. You have
Lore-lor high-lor low or low or low. So you draw out your PD area, which is you know
discount and premium zones
So you want to wait for price to come back into premium zone
Right, which is above the 0.5 level and then you look for ABC formation
The C leg goes into some sort of a POI it could be an auto block
it could be fair value gap and it could be yeah so to refine it even further what
I do is when I have a POI here let's say on the 15 minute right what I would
do is I would drop down to five minute and refine that POI even more to make it
smaller okay so sometimes what can happen if you have a 15 minute POI price
can sometimes do this and then hit the you know the refined OB on five minute
and then give you an ABC setup. So that is sometimes I do something that I do
sometimes. So this is how I personally approach ABC guys. I first of all look at
the market structure and how do you look so what you want to do is you want to
look back 25 days. Okay. So in the last 25 days, if the market structure is making lower, lower,
lower, high, lower, lower, high. So in real market conditions, limited, delete this, the market
structure is going to look something like this. Okay, it's not going to be a clear down trend. It's
going to have movements like this. Okay, it's not going to be clean. So as long as the price is
Going down as long as it keeps going down. You just look for shot positions and that is why this method requires a lot of patience guys
It requires higher time frame like for our timeframe. Yeah, it could you could use one hour
But I do not recommend that. I mean you can use ABC on any time frame except one minute
We can use it on one minute as well, but I do not recommend that time frame trust me. It's just not okay
but
See the high time frame is gonna make you profitable
This is it. I'm telling you guys just build this patience to trade high time for him guys
I know I know you want to see you want to get that dopamine hit when you are trading on like one minute and five minute
And you see your trades going to profits and you're like wow I'm making money
But that is a bad habit and you're gonna get addicted to trading and when you get addicted to trading you're gonna take
Five to ten trades per day, which is really really bad guys and you're gonna
and prevent straight and get a blow your account.
So just stay away from that.
And similarly, if you're looking at a market structure
that is bullish and the price
in making high, high, high, high, high, high, high, low,
then you only have to look for long setups.
So a long setup looks something like this.
You would have A, B, C going into,
to see like going into some sort of auto block, right?
And you look for shift in market structure on a smaller
timeframe like that.
And you literally just take your entry.
Right?
So I'll give you guys a couple of examples and then it's going to be clear.
Guys, so here is example number one.
As you can see for the past month we have been bullish, right?
So we created this higher high.
So we can expect higher prices. So now this right here is our P o and you can see
price came here tap to do this level and forcing the early buyers to like go
long but watch what happens. We have an a b c pattern inside the p y which is a nice
thing like it doesn't necessarily have to form inside the p y. The only need
see the sealer going to here, but if this occurs, that is absolutely fine as well.
So let's go to the 15 minute timeframe to look for marker structure shift.
So as you can see, there is no clear structure here.
So in this scenario, what you can do is you can drop down to five minutes.
Okay? And when you drop down to five minutes, you can see that we have the structure.
So I want to see a body close above this level.
So let's see what happens and I believe we do have a body close right here
So we look for extreme water block which is right here as you can see
This right here, so I'm gonna mark this out
okay, perfect
and
I'm gonna take my entry from this level probably put my stuff just below this low right here and
I
I would target one to two, but let's see how this goes.
So price comes back, taps in, right?
And just watch that move.
It's crazy.
So price went ahead and took out this high right here.
So remember, we knew that we were bullish for the past month, right?
And as you know, we took the straight right here and we targeted this low.
So that is like prime ABC.
Your take profit level was hit.
And right off of that, you have a reversal.
So I'll give you guys another example.
All right guys, so here is example number two.
You can see we are bullish.
We had a breakout structure identifying
and showing us that the trend is to the upside.
The market structure is bullish.
Okay, that's all you need to identify market structure guys and trends.
So look at the last 20 or 30 days.
And if the market is making hard highs,
higher lows, higher highs, then that is plus point.
Okay, so right here you can see we have this auto blog
and we also have this volume and balance right here.
So you can see that, let's remove this from now.
Let's consider it auto blog as our PUI.
just for the sake of this example.
So right here you can see we have A, B and C.
The C leg goes into our PUI.
So let's drop down to 15 minute time from.
And let me show you how this goes.
I wanna look for a shift in my, okay,
so we have a market structure shift now.
So if I look at here, this is the first kind
of the fair value gap, right?
So this is our autoblock.
I would take my long position just right here.
I would put my stop below this low or this low.
So I would target the high of the b leg,
which is this.
So let's see how this plays out.
So we get a tap, right?
So let me do this.
Boom, look at the power guys.
1 to 10 secured within a couple of RS guys.
That is how powerful it becomes when you are following the trend.
You are taking trades in the direction of the trend.
And also, you are using POIs with ABCs.
So and you are also using higher time frame.
Higher time frame is the king guys.
Just stay away from low time frames.
If you want to take trades like these,
because when you're using higher time frames,
You're gonna see moves like this.
All right.
So it's simple guys.
Remember the rules we look at
high time frame market structure, right?
Trend.
After that we mark out the premium
slash discount zones.
Wait for price to come below slash above 0.5 level of fib.
Wait for ABC for formation below slash above 0.5 level and the C leg goes into that
POI.
Now, when I say that C-leg must go into that POI, what can happen is the whole ABC setup
can form in that POI.
So it doesn't necessarily have to be the C-leg.
But if the ABC pattern occurs in that auto block, when you have, like let's suppose you
have a POI marked out.
And what can happen sometime?
price gonna touch this auto block push up and then create another an ABC pattern inside the
auto block right so it's gonna look something like this boom boom boom boom simple as that so I
hope you guys enjoyed this video and this lecture if you have any more questions you can ask them
in the discord and I'll see you guys in the next video.